[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
b
[Music]
[Music]
difficult
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
river
[Music]
ralph waldo emerson once
quoted that
nothing great can ever be achieved
without enthusiasm
i have a lot of enthusiasm
[Music]
this is northlands in flemington new
jersey
northlands is the world's largest model
railroad
well i guess you know everybody has a
passion for something my thing was
trains had trains around the christmas
tree as a kid wherever i lived i'm
planning track plans and then over 18
years i added five basements onto the
house
from that i got fairly good at making
mountains and bridges and design work
and we decided to give it to the world
so we tore it all down bought this land
built northlands any given day we run
between 85 and 90 trains
some of the details in northlands inside
about forty thousand feet of track about
four 000 buildings
over 400 bridges many of the mountains
in here are three and a half stories
high
most things in here are scratch built
underneath the entire superstructure
there's enough lumber to build about 42
large houses
takes a few hours to go through for the
average person
to see everything
we went millions into debt
to build this place everywhere i thought
we were nuts the only one that believed
that what i wanted to do was my wife and
she was totally with me on this big time
it's an artistic endeavor it's a gift to
the world of what i can do
and it makes
a lot of people happy
[Music]
in london ontario there lives a man
whose basement is unlike anything you've
ever seen
this is robert wardoff hi my name is
robert wardoff robert has been playing
the same dungeons and dragons campaign
for over 30 years 35 years to be exact
i'm sorry that's okay
welcome would you like to play a dwarven
rogue
you look like a rogue wait let's back up
for a second dungeons and dragons is a
fantasy role-playing game where a group
of people come together and play out
adventures dictated by a dungeon master
these adventures also known as campaigns
are set in the dungeons and dragons
world and normally have an endpoint or
they just fizzle out due to people's
lack of commitment but robert is in a
league of his own and here's why
the dude has a serious collection i
think our collection of miniatures is
around twenty thousand
and then over the years i discovered
terrain ultimately i'm a collector also
and a lot of my enjoyment comes from
being able to get new stuff and to put
new stuff on the table so the players
are constantly coming across new
settings
because it's a game that doesn't stick
to one particular campaign setting i'm
able to use any figs that actually fit
the world
and so it is a long process but over 35
years
you can develop quite a collection as
robert's collection grew so did the
number of players word began to spread
about the never-ending campaign we have
people coming from all over the country
to play off and flying in wait all over
the country that's right
robert can we play now
these are some of the people who play in
robert's game where are you guys from
i flew in from saskatoon saskatchewan i
drove in from toronto brussels ontario
camoca ontario calgary alberta hold on
what happens if people can't fly in or
drive to robert's house to play
hey everyone
problem solved
[Music]
the game has always been determined
really through a friendship um it's
really been a way that i keep my friends
together i knew early on that if i was
able to create a game that was good
enough and that means it had to be
better than video games it had to be
better than any other game they could
find that they would keep coming no
matter where i was and so that takes
again imagination and it takes change
and it takes having a system that is
constantly dynamic that is changing that
is growing and that is constantly
getting better
[Music]
in southern pennsylvania there is a
battlefield a battlefield so important
that it is thought to be the turning
point of the american civil war this is
a story about that place
it's also a story about cats
thousands and thousands of little cats
[Music]
this is rebecca hi i'm rebecca and this
is her twin sister ruth hi i'm ruth and
we run a museum of dioramas that are
made with handmade civil war cats
civil
war
cats the combination of a childhood love
for clay cats and a strong fascination
with the american civil war it started
out as a hobby that we just did
as kids putzing around in our bedrooms
that bit of child's play led to a
full-fledged museum which opened in 2013
[Music]
the two of us discussed how much do we
want to emphasize the cat thing because
we don't want to come off as cutesy cats
the idea is the stories of the men not
so much the fact that they're cats they
just are cats because
they're cats
incredibly each of these scenes is to
scale one-eighth of an inch equals one
foot in cat feet and so each one of our
soldiers represents one soldier who
would have been on the field we'll
calculate the numbers that would have
been left in the regiment and we'll fill
it in with that many cats soldiers so
for example low around top we're going
to eventually have about 5 000 soldiers
on it typically one like the angle we
figure took us about four and a half
years the little round top diorama we
figure is more of a five or six year
diorama
we really just want to make the civil
war more approachable i guess for people
so they can relate to the history and
have more of a connection with the men
and the women involved
now that the word of this cat museum is
out all the people who love cats come in
and now not only are they seeing our
dioramas of falling in love with the
five and a half thousand little furry
smiles smiling at them
but they're also learning the stories
and suddenly they have an appreciation
of gettysburg and the history just
because they came to see the cats
[Music]
where can you see the eiffel tower
monsan michelle and the arc de triomphe
all within a few steps of each other
france of course
well
miniature france
[Music]
located two hours outside of paris
miniature france is a theme park made in
the image of real france but at 1 30 of
the original size
[Music]
the park is 12 acres in size and
features 117 different monuments
miniature france was built by a team of
50 model makers and landscape architects
ensuring that each model is an exact
replica of its larger counterpart
to make this hybrid city come to life
there are animated trains cars and
planes that move around the region
[Music]
and while you might not have time to see
all the real france has to offer in one
day you can make your way around this
park in one afternoon
although your photos might not be to
scale
[Music]
a lot of people consider mini golf to be
very benign and all fun and games but at
this level it can be a cut throat
competition
among the greatest players in the world
[Music]
my name is matt male i'm a professional
mini golfer
[Music]
i was a regular golfer ever since
childhood i started at about eight years
old
and putting was always the greatest
facet of my game the idea of doing
nothing but putting for 18 holes
instantly appealed to me and i just
began practicing a lot
people don't realize that mini golf is a
highly precise sport
improvement can come
very tediously
to be competitive it really requires
an extensive
mapping of each hole
and we can be out here for up to 10
hours a day or so for several days
before a tournament
when i first arrive at a course
i diagnose the holes
i want to come up with a clear plan of
attack on each hole and then just it's a
matter of repetition from there
[Music]
we are at the
2016 mini golf masters in north myrtle
beach south carolina this tournament is
the premier event each year in mini golf
it draws players from all over the world
the green jacket is the most coveted
prize in mini golf
the competition is very fierce the
players here are the best of the best
and it's an immense challenge because
even a stretch of five bad minutes or
ten bad minutes can disqualify you from
contention
just a tiny miscue here or there can
spell major disaster on one hole
[Music]
i really do have an authentic admiration
of what the winner had to do to to
perform
under the pressure of such a major
tournament because
i i know from experience how hard it is
mini golf's not a sport for everyone
there's constant frustration there's
constant adversity
it
it rewards patience and it rewards
determination
and it never gets old to see the ball go
in the hole
i don't think that thrill will ever go
away
you